my name is michael burton and i'm
working with Professor hoberg on an
aircraft cost optimization model and the
reason I'm doing it is because aircraft
cost a lot of money and they take a long
time to build specifically they take a
long time to go through a design cycle
though it can be like months or even
years to go through this and the reason
is they go through an optimization for
performance and then they do a cost
analysis and they say oh we don't have
enough money to build we need to
redesign and they go through this loop
for a long time so I'm proposing why
don't we optimize cost and performance
at the same time and that will allow us
to eliminate a lot of design variables
and because i'm using a form of
optimization called geometric
programming I can see the train off
instantaneously so in this example I'm
optimizing I'm maximizing range and
minimizing costs and I can immediately
see that you know an order of seconds
you know how much it's going to cost to
go this far and so this project is
developing more sophisticated model so i
can see like if i want to go this much
faster and this much farther how much
will it cost me how much is it going to
cost to manufacture how much is in it
costed to design and this is possible
because i'm using a form of optimization
that is not currently used in aerospace
industry and it's very fast and very
accurate and i think it's going to work